all right why don't we get started today
we're going to move on to finally the
most realistic market structure we
talked about perfectly competitive
market so now that was a very useful
extreme example to help us think about
economic efficiency we then flipped over
to talk about the somewhat more
realistic case of monopoly but still
very few markets have only one
participant a true monopoly is rare in
the private market what most markets are
marked are by are probably more features
of oligopoly which is a market with a
small group of firms competing with each
other but with barriers to entry that
keep out an unlimited number of firms
say about these as markets where there
are some barriers to entry so firms just
can't cautiously enter an exit like they
could in our IBM Dell example but where
there's small enough eros entry that a
few firms have gotten in not just one so
it's not a natural monopoly it's not
like one the only one forum can be in
there multiple firms are in there but
they only know that to compete with each
other not with the big wide world okay
so for example the classic example an
oligopoly is should be the auto industry
it's a auto manufacturers clearly
compete clearly if you watch any
sporting event and watch how much
advertising that goes on they clearly
are competing with each other that can
prank each other all the time
but there's only all on most of the cars
in the world are produced by fewer than
ten auto manufacturers the notion that
we have but a perfectly competitive
market of thousands of sellers selling
identical goods it's clearly not right
when it comes to buying a car so that's
sort of the model we're gonna want to
focus on for the next few lectures
now within Oh within an oligopoly market
whenever we think about this market we
want to start by noting that within this
market the limited set of competitors
can behave in two ways then we can
behave cooperatively cooperatively or
non cooperatively okay cooperative means
they can form what's called a cartel so
when there's an oligopoly market and the
firm's cooperatively get together and
make decisions that's called the cartel
the most famous example of which is OPEC
the Organization of Petroleum Exporting
Countries which are the set of countries
that control about two-thirds of the
words world's oil led by Saudi Arabia is
the major player in in OPEC it's a
cartel about a dozen nations and what
they do is they control the vast
majority of the world's oil reserves and
by behaving cooperatively they
essentially turn themselves into a
monopoly OPEC acts as if they've got
sort of got the monopoly on oil
certainly they they used to now it's
getting harder other Kanaan OPEC
countries are started producing more oil
and breaking down but for a long time
they were essentially the co-operative
Peru savoia land act essentially like a
monopoly and they made lots of profits
like a monopoly they kept prices high
they kept production inefficiently low
and they made lots of money okay however
um that's a great outcome for producers
but as we'll talk about next time it's
actually a hard outcome to enforce
turned out to be hard to keep cartels
together and so typically oligopoly
markets behave in a non cooperative way
with the participants competing with
each other not cooperating with each
other and in this case you can actually
get them driving their profits down far
below the monopoly level and indeed
perhaps even all the way to the
competitive level so you think about
markets as a competitive is one extreme
and the monopolies the other extreme
oligopoly in between a cooperative
oligopoly market like cartel will end up
close to the monopoly outcome a non
cooperative market well it's somewhere
in between and we're gonna model today
is we're in between do they end up okay
now to think about this we're gonna have
to turn to a tool which has really
become a dominant tool in economics over
the last 40 years which is the tool of
game theory
game theory so basically we could think
of all look up we're gonna think of
oligopoly firms as engaging in a game
okay and as with any game you need to
sort of know two things one is you need
to know what's the strategy and the
second is you need to know when is the
game over kind of what's the equilibrium
and that's sort of essentially what you
tell with any game and so basically what
we're gonna do the key with game theory
is that we are going to define the
equilibrium and that's going to yield
for us the strategy that players are
going to use however equilibrium in a
game is not well-defined it's like a set
of rules that are printed out like
monopoly in a non cooperative oligopoly
market the equilibrium you have to
actually come up with different concepts
of what equilibrium is there's not a
hard-and-fast scientific rule and the
typical one that's used is called the
Nash equilibrium the Nash equilibrium
named for the John Nash the famous
mathematician who economists have
claimed as their own even though it's
really a mathematician but we get in the
Nobel Prize anyway and you know if you
think of this in comments probably one
of most famous you know you all know
about the movie and book Beautiful Mind
he is basically the father of of game
theory okay so basically what is the
Nash equilibrium the Nash equilibria is
defined as the point at which no player
wants to change their strategy given
what the other players are doing so the
point at which no player wants to change
its strategy given what the other
players are doing so in lodz every
player is happy with where they are
given what every other players decided
I'm happy to do what I've decided so
I've got a strategy and given the
strategy other players are using if I'm
happy with my strategy then that's an
equilibrium okay so this is a super
abstract concept so let's illustrate it
with an example and the classic example
of game theory is the prisoner's dilemma
which many of you I'm sure know about
maybe than most of you but let's just go
through it this is the thing from the
old cop movies you see where they arrest
two guys and they put them in separate
rooms and they basically interrogate
them separately ok and what they say is
um they're put in separate rooms and
let's say that these guys get told to
follow and they each get told separately
the following thing they get told that
right now if nothing else happens
there's enough evidence to send them
each away for one year however they're
told if they turn on their friend and
say and say their friends guilty then
they go free and their friend gets five
years if their friend turns on them then
the friend goes free and they get five
years but if they both turn on each
other
they both get two years okay set up as
if they both stay silent they both get
one year if one turns then that person
gets to leave in the other person gets
five years but if they both turn then
these get two years so how do we think
about decision making that context the
way we do that is we write down we call
a payoff matrix we sort of write down a
matrix form this decision so let's think
about it what a playoff matrix look like
up here a prisoner B and here you have
prisoner a for centre a and prisoner a
can remain silent or they can talk and
prisoner B can remain silent
or they can talk okay
and then we just write down what are the
outcomes or the payoffs from these
different strategies so prisoner a says
nothing and prisoner B says nothing then
a gets one year and B gets one year if
prisoner a says nothing and prisoner B
says oh yeah prisoner a he's definitely
guilty then prisoner a gets five years
and prisoner being at zero years if the
opposite happens if prisoner he says
yeah B's guilty and B doesn't say
anything about a then a gets zero years
and B gets five years but if they both
say the other ones guilty then they each
get two years okay that's the payoff
matrix okay and now we want to ask given
this payoff matrix what is the right
strategy for each prisoner to pursue and
the way we do this in the Nash
equilibria makaan cept is we look for a
dominant strategy it's very strategy
that I would pursue regardless of what
the other person does and if there is
I'll pursue that because remember the
national Calibri concept is what do I
want to do given what the other person's
doing if I have a strategy I want to do
no matter what the other person is doing
then I'll do it so and ask is there a
dominant strategy is there a strategy
there's the best thing to do no matter
what the other guy does okay well
clearly if they're cooperating if these
were these were stupid police and they
sat in the same room told us then left
the two guys cooperating said well
clearly the dominant cooperative
strategy is for all of us to remain
silent that's the dominant coopera
strategy then as a team we only get two
total years in jail where everything
gives much more many more years in jail
so they're buddies and they trust each
other and they cooperate then that's the
closest right strategy well let's say
the police are smart and put them in
separate rooms
okay well what's the dominant
non-cooperative strategy what is the
strategy that a or b that aides say a
should produce yeah why
[Music]
in silence you talk you get zero and if
they're talking they talking you talk as
well you get 2 vs. 5 exactly 4 person or
a in this first row compared the first
row left first column will say prisoner
be silent then clearly you're better off
talking than not talking 0 rather than 1
let's say prisoner B talks then you're
still better off talking than not
talking so no matter what B does you
should talk
likewise prisoner B no matter what a
does B should talk so the
non-cooperative room is actually this
outcome they both end up talking you get
sort of a race to the bottom
the non-cooperative outcome is much
worse than if they could have cooperated
ok so basically what you get is that the
non-cooperative equilibrium is always
worse for the players than the
co-operative equilibria and this was
like an unbelievable insight of Nash
before Nash we always thought
competition was always than ever we're
good with some more competitions better
for the reasons we taught you in the
first 10 or 10 or 12 lectures of this
class Nash was the first one to say no
actually competition can be bad
cooperation can be better as you
remember the scene in a beautiful mind
where they're picking up girls in the
bar and he describes sort of basically a
Nash strategy ok how competition lead to
the worst outcome ok and basically
that's what you see here that
competition can actually lead to a worse
outcome than cooperation and that was
really sort of Nash's sort of brilliant
insight now um this is a sort of a cute
example of prisoners but actually but
well for two points first of all this
generally shows you how you do gain fear
with Nash with Nash equilibria basically
you look at the payoff matrix you find
the dominant strategy and then you find
where those dominant strategies
intersect and here the dominant
strategies intersect at this cell
therefore that's the equilibrium okay so
that's basically how you do game theory
you know you know
getting through kindergarten level okay
you look at the matrix you find each
player's dominus strategy and you find
the point at which those dominant
strategies intersect and at that point
that's the equilibrium now that's all
well and good for sort of a simple
example like this but let's actually
apply to an economics example let's
think about advertising
so think about Coke and Pepsi okay um
now right now let's think about their
decision advertise now obviously this is
a simple problem obviously Pepsi should
just be illegal because cokes just way
better but sadly it's not and sometimes
I have to drink Pepsi and I'm very sad
but nonetheless in the real world we
have Coke impacts they have to decide
how much to advertise now the dominant
cooperative strategy would be to say
look advertising cost us a ton of money
let's just split the market
let's have monopoly market and just
split it we're close to splitting it
anyway cokes got some more of it we're
close to splitting let's just split it
yeah why different than the
cooperative's that's that's imposed not
by Coke and Pepsi jointly that's opposed
by Pepsi saying to a university campus
for example we will only we will cut you
a better deal if you'll agree not to
sell coke that's not cooperation that's
competition okay so the quad there's a
proper strategy what if they don't
cooperate okay
well let's imagine we are the following
payoff matrix okay you've got Pepsi up
here and they can advertise or not
advertise and you've got Coke here and
they can advertise or not advertise and
let's say the payoff matrix is the
following let's say if both Pepsi and
Coke let's say that the total um let's
say the total amount of profit to be
made is 16 whatever a billion whatever
units want to make it 16 billion okay
and let's say if there's no advertising
Coke gets 8m Pepsi gets eight okay
but let's say but let's say advertising
cost money it costs five five billion so
let's say if they both advertise then
they still end up splitting the market
but they only make three C equals three
P equals three so it's a I'm sorry it's
the obviou advertising yes you're right
C equals three P equals three and here C
equals eight P equals eight okay so
basically they are so basically of a
situation where they both end up
splitting the market either way but they
just split a smaller net profit if they
advertise so clearly they'd rather be
here than here but what happens in the
off-diagonal elements well let's say
also that if coke advertises but Pepsi
does not then let's say Coke ends up
making 13 billion and Pepsi ends up
making - I'm sorry if Coke advertises
and if Coke advertises and Pepsi does
not adjust what my teen and Pepsi makes
negative - they actually lose money
because a fixed cost then don't sell
anything nobody buys perhaps their to
lose money and let's say if Pepsi
advertises and coke doesn't then coke
makes negative - and Pepsi makes 13 okay
so actually if you don't advertise
you're really screwed and the other guys
really screwed yeah this doesn't move
the cost of advertising but it's just
coke you know gets gets a huge market
expands its market okay so now let's
play the game
well now let's say your coke you say
well if I advertise if I advertise and
Pepsi advertises I make three but if I
don't advertising Pepsi advertises I
make negative - so I should advertise if
I advertise Pepsi doesn't advertise that
make 13 if I if I don't advertise and
Pepsi doesn't advertise I make eight so
either way my dominant strategies to
advertise and likewise Pepsi does the
same thing it's actually I screwed up
writing this compared to my notes but
it's good because it shows
you flip the matrix but the logic is the
same it hopes you sort of not just
memorize cells little a matrix but learn
the logic the point is either way the
dominant strategist to advertise so they
both advertise so real-world example of
how you can end up now so much Oh pepsin
coke do this
actually there was industry that did
this so when I was a kid you never ever
saw ads for liquor on TV
there were beer ads and wine ads but no
hard alcohol that no bourbon no whiskey
no nothing gin all this always you know
captain Morgan's ads we see now they
didn't exist when I was a kid but it
wasn't because the law it was because
the hard liquor industry cooperatively
agreed none that would advertise this
actually imposed a cooperative Librium
and then that broke down I don't know
the story of how it broke down but
something broke down now they all
advertise and they're probably all worse
off than they were when they just didn't
advertise okay we'll talk next time
about why it probably broke down I don't
know the stories well I have a rough
sense and I'll talk about that next time
but this is the point of how a
non-cooperative living can drive you to
a bad outcome okay now basically this
doesn't just apply to prisoners or
business that applies to people too so
let's say poor Hector back there is had
a fight with his girlfriend okay and
they've had a big fight they've been
gone a little while they've had a big
fight and Hector's got to decide do I
apologize so don't wait for her to
apologize okay
well the last thing Hector wants is to
go up there and apologize have mercy
forget it I'm breaking up with you
that'd be the worst okay if he knows
she's gonna be like oh I'm sorry too
then he'd be happy to do it but what if
he goes she has no I'm breaking up with
you will then and she's thinking the
same thing so what happens they break up
okay
we've been through this many times in
our lives this is the non-cooperative
strategy okay basically if you don't the
other person is gonna do your dominant
strategies to be an [ __ ] okay and
basically that happens a lot in the
context of the real world okay
so now we have this sort of sad sounding
outcome that basically game theory leads
to bad outcomes for producers at least
but
this is what's exciting about game
theory so when I went to grad school
back you know when dinosaurs roamed the
earth game theory was sort of taught
barely in the sequence it was sort of
like an extra course taught a little bit
now it sort of dominates the teaching of
microeconomics in economics and it
doesn't dominate but it's a whole like
component of our core microeconomics
education because it's given such a cool
set of tools to think about these
decisions now I can't give you even 1%
of the flavor of game theory if you want
to learn more I highly suggest you take
1412 which is our game theory class and
you can learn a ton but let me use sort
of one interesting wrinkle of the kind
of things game theory can do to go
beyond this and that's to imagine that
Coke and Pepsi are not playing a
one-shot game but a repeated game
repeated game ok so now imagine that um
coke says to Pepsi the following I
promise to not advertise as long as you
don't advertise but if you ever
advertise I will advertise forever ok
coke system FC I promise not to
advertise as long as you don't advertise
but if I ever catch you advertising I'm
gonna advertise forever ok so now a
match think about Pepsi's choice in
period one Pepsi is choice in period 1
impaired 1 they could say ha stupid coke
I'm gonna jump on them and advertise
they promised me I could advertise I'm
gonna make so Pepsi advertises they're
gonna make 13 in period 1 right because
cokes taking themselves off to the side
but after period 1 they're gonna make 8
forever
no they're gonna sorry they're gonna
make three forever because cokes can
advertise they're gonna advertise they
break down to the non-cooperative
equilibrium ok
if Pepsi advertise now what if Pepsi
doesn't advertise as well as it doesn't
advertise then it gets to deal with Coke
so it makes eight forever so now we'll
talk later in the course about how you
my numbers that happen different times
to trust me a forever is a way better
deal Don thirteen and three forever okay
so actually by having this be a repeated
game coke has solved the prisoner's
dilemma it's essentially imposed a
cooperative equilibrium on the problem
okay so that's how a repeated game can
fix this but as we're getting through it
gets really exciting that only works if
this game never ends because once Coke
or Pepsi thinks there's an end to the
game the entire thing breaks down okay
so imagine for example the coke makes
the offer to Pepsi but Pepsi's worried
that in 10 years the government's going
to outlaw soda okay
the government you know has said look
we're heading that direction so does
gonna be legal in 10 years so I don't
want to do this
so in that case know that I'm sorry not
that I want to I so I have that in my
mind so Coke offers the deal now what do
I think well let's think about Pepsi's
decision in the ninth year they've made
eight eight eight eight eight and they
get to your nine now in year nine they
know that next year there's no more game
so what should they do advertise grab
the thirteen in the last period because
Coke can't punish them because the
game's over
but Coke knows this so it's Coke gonna
do in the ninth year advertise its can
advertise so they're both gonna make so
so they're both gonna make a three
well if Pepsi knows cokes can advertise
than that ninth year no matter what
what's your pet's you in the eighth year
advertise and if Coke knows pets can
advertise an eighth year bunch of coke
do and so on and ends up that they both
advertise all the way through so the
game breaks down if it's an end this is
really kind of neat and this is what
game through is all about is how do you
think through these more complicated
scenarios that are much more complicated
the prisoner's dilemma and actually
think about how firms and individuals
might actually behave yeah
these contracts
earlier sure that's much and once again
that's exact that's what you cover in a
field of course like game theories what
about alternative forms of contracting
with exclusionary contractor what we
call tying in contracting that's great
and they would but that's that's why you
got to take 1412 okay yeah
like
yeah the way I've set this problem up if
they could commit to that that'd be
right but you'd have to commit to it
because then the funds the period the
period the Pepsi promised to take off if
they actually advertised that period
then cokes screwed so that would work as
a repeated game solution but it wouldn't
work as a as a non repeated game so as
again as the work is an infinite
repeated game but not a non infinite
repeated game okay
good question okay other questions all
right so that's the basic game theory
that's just a taste for the excitement
that you can live with game theory but
in fact in economics we like to write
that these fun examples but we really
prefer to do math so let's actually
think about the math of how we take game
theory concepts and put them in practice
and that's we that the way we do that is
through the concept of the cournot model
the cournot model of non cooperative
oligopolies okay so it's the cournot
model of non cooperative oligopoly is
the standard workhorse model takes this
intuition and puts it into the kind of
optimizing math we've been doing this so
far this class okay so let's now let's
imagine non cooperative case but now
let's imagine there's not just two
choices but realistically there's a
whole set of choices okay then how would
you behave in the in that case so let's
imagine that there's two airlines United
in American United America two so we're
gonna have a oligopolistic to firm
airline industry obviously the math can
extend to more firms but just to start
now and I'll talk about that next
lecture but for now imagine a two firm
industry United an American and because
the hub-and-spoke system we discussed
last time let's imagine of the only two
folks that go from Boston Chicago okay
because this hub-and-spoke system the
only folks to go from Boston Chicago at
night in America and they do in fact
dominate that line so let's imagine the
only folks and say no other firms could
get peed in this and this on this route
because they can't get slots at the
airport so the question is how do these
firms decide how many flights to run
it's not just advertised don't it's
literally a continuous decision of how
many flights to run every day and how
much to charge
okay they've got to make that decision
and the Nash equilibrium here we call a
core know the sort of subset of Nash for
this examples called the cournot
equilibrium and the cournot equilibrium
exists when a firm chooses a quantity
such that given the quantity chosen by
the other firm they don't want to change
so a firm chooses essentially the profit
maximizing quantity given the quantity
chosen by the other firm okay and if
that profit maximizing quantity okay
then that you're in cournot equilibrium
if you have chosen a quantity that is
profit maximizing given what the other
firm is doing okay so basically how do
we how do we actually carry this out
okay let's talk about the steps okay so
the first step here's I'm going to talk
intuitively about the math what we're
gonna do and I'm gonna talk
mathematically and graphically we
actually do they're essentially three
steps in solving for the cournot
equilibrium the first is ask how your
demand changes when some of its absorbed
by other firms so the first is solve for
your residual demand function what does
your demand curve look like given what
the other firm does that's step one step
two is that you develop a marginal
revenue which is a function of the other
firms quantity little Q it's multiple
firms okay the other firms that's really
bad hard to read the other firm's
quantity so it's your marginal revenue
function typically it's a function I'm
sorry of both your quantity and the
other firm's quantity a function of both
your quantity and the other firm's
quantity we developed marginal revenues
as a function of your own quantity we
know how to do that now we're developing
our job as a function of your quantity
and the other firm's quantity then you
simply set this marginal revenue equal
to marginal cost and that delivers you a
conditional answer that delivers you
your optimal quantity as a function of
the other
firms quanti okay
well that doesn't do it's a whole lot of
good except there's two firms so the
fourth step is we do the same thing for
the other firm and get the same kind of
equation then what do we have two
equations and two unknowns so we solve
okay so what we do here is essentially
the same thing we did before but now
your marginal revenue is not just a
function of your own clients a function
the other guy's quantity same with the
other guy that gives you two equations
two unknowns we solve and the point at
which both firms are happy is the
cournot equilibrium okay
so let's actually that's confusing so
let's actually look at that let's start
we'll do suppose graphically and
mathematically let's start with figure
thirteen one okay to make things easy
let's start by imagining then American
Airlines is a monopoly let's start with
the world with them American Airlines
monopoly okay and let's say that the
demand function is P equals 339 minus Q
that's an Amman for flights from Boston
to Chicago okay and let's say that the
marginal cost to make life easy I could
have a cost function make your life
difficult but maybe someday I'll do that
but for now to make your life easy
let's just say there's a flat marginal
cost of 147 dollars okay I'm not gonna
laugh or not gonna make life difficult
with solving for marginal cost functions
for now it's just him a flat marginal
cost of 147 no matter how many flights
they do its $147 per passenger so if
your monopolist how do you solve this
problem
well first you derive your marginal
revenue function
well what's marginal revenue function
well revenues is P times Q which is 339
Q minus Q squared so your marginal
revenue function is 339 minus 2q
that's your marver to reginal function
if you're the monopolist what's your
marginal cost well already said it's 147
and then you just solve and when you
solve that you get the Q the optimal
quantity is 96 flights and then how do
you get the price how do you get the
price of an awfully problem how do we
know what the what the price is
yeah you're gonna plug it back into the
demand curve you got to take that
quantity plug it back to the main curve
so the price is 339 minus 96 or 243 okay
so I just solved the monopoly problem
quickly but that's um but that's what we
did what we've done already in this
class and you could see that in the
graph here okay in Figure 13 1 you've
got demand curve which is 3 P equals 339
minus Q you've got a supply curve which
is a flat marginal cost at 147 you
develop a marginal revenue function
which is 339 minus 2q as in our previous
example that's just basically an inward
shift of the demand function that
intersects marginal cost at 96 flights
okay we have this a thousand passengers
per quarter doesn't really matter the
unit's ignore the you know it's just all
standardization okay and then to get the
price you read it off the demand curve
you say ninety six flights means a price
of 243 first flight okay that's what we
do if American was a monopolist now
however Americans not a monopolist
American deals with United and American
doesn't know what United's going to do
so what does American do well let's say
America now has to deal with the fact
that the evening has to recognize that
the demand it's got its own demand
function Q a which is the total quantity
in the market minus Q you okay
so it has a residual demand function
which is the total demand in the market
- what United sells
okay so suppose for example American
thinks Americans got a spy inside United
an American says ha
I think United's gonna fly 64 flights ok
so imagine America thinks United's gonna
fly 64 64 flights well in that case it
would say well in that case my arm if
they're gonna fight 64 flights then my
demand function is P sub a equals 339
minus Q sub a minus 64 right because the
big quantity okay the big quantity is is
little Q a plus little Q U so my demand
function is 339 minus Q sub a minus 64
okay or in other words my residual
demand function is that P sub a equals
339 equals
275 275 minus QA so if I think United's
gonna fly 64 flights then my effective
demand function is 275 minus Q and then
I'm done then I just solve for what
would I do as a monopolist given the
other guys flying 64 flights so you can
see that in Figure 13 - okay so I have a
demand function I say well if United's
gonna fly 64 flights that demand
function gets shifted in by 64 and then
the same thing I did before I solve for
marginal revenue okay I solve for
marginal revenue and I intersect that
with marginal cost that's gonna happen
at 64 flights and a price of 211 okay so
basically it's the same exercise it's
not that hard you just first take out
what United's gonna do the problem is
American doesn't have a spy they don't
really know what United's gonna do they
have to essentially up a strategy given
the possibilities of what United might
do they have to say look I don't know
what Q sub u is so I have to devise my
optimal strategy given Q sub u
okay in the Lord's I have to
simultaneously solve for what I would do
at every possible quantity United would
sell if to solve what I would do for
every possible quantity I would sell and
we call this developing your reaction or
best response curve your reaction curve
or your best response curve which is
what is the best thing to do given what
the other guy is doing what is the best
thing to do given what the other guys
doing okay you can see that in Figure 13
3 we show how that works okay
that shows best response curves so for
example look at the intersection on the
y-axis where the red line hits the
vertical hits the y-axis
that was our monopoly equilibrium I'm
sorry where the where the I'm sorry
where the blue line it's the x-axis my
bad we're doing American look at where
the blue line hits the x-axis that is
assuming zero united flights right where
the blue line it's the x-axis is where
the zero united flights
well we know what american would do
there they would fly 96 flights we
already solve that now look at the point
the point where United is flying 64
flights
well we also know what American would do
then we read off the wheat we know that
we solved in the previous figure they
would then do 64 flights and in general
what that blue line is is for every
quantity that United flies what does
American want to fly okay now let's
actually do and so meanwhile United is
doing the same mathematics imagine to
make life easy will almost always do
this to make life easy
imagine United has the same marginal
cost American and obviously faces the
same market demand curve
well then literally their math is
totally symmetric if American was it in
the market you'd have with the red line
intersects the vertical axis if American
was flying 0 united with fly 96 light
because their problem is identical to
Americans monopoly problem likewise so
that red the red line is united best
response curve so we've graphed for
every possible amount of flights that
United does what's Americans optimal
amount of flights we've solved for every
amount of flights that American does
which United off the amount of flights
where those lines intersect is the
cournot equilibrium why is that the
konoka Librium because at that point
both firms are doing the best they can
give them what the other firms chosen in
other words to say this is given what
the other firms doing neither firm wants
to deviate the profit maximizing choice
is to be where they are given the other
firms behavior okay so basically the
cournot equilibrium is the only
equilibrium that's possible
in this market okay so and why is that
so for example imagine that American
came in and said look I like doing 96
flights
I love being monopolist I'm just dude 96
flights and I'm gonna charge vomited
nine six flights I'm in charge of $43
well in that case American United I'm
sorry would happily come in at two
hundred and forty two dollars and
undercut them and sell lots of flights
because that's still well above marginal
cost so that's not an equilibrium
because because United and American are
choosing different outcomes it's only I
could have they both it's they're both
to the point where the same outcome
makes them both happy okay so that's the
graphics let's actually do the let's do
the math here let's do the cournot math
okay in general the residual demand for
American is that P equals 339 minus Q a
minus Q you okay remember big Q is Q a
plus Q you so since big Q since the
demand function is 339 minus big Q I
simply broke big Q into Q a and Q you
okay it's not meat this all unclear
simply broke up the big Q into those two
components so that means that Americans
revenue function that's called revenue a
revenue for American is 339 times Q a
minus Q a squared minus Q aqu this is a
new term this was the old this was the
old revenue function we had when they
were innopolis now I've got this new
term that didn't exist before
so that means their marginal revenue for
American is now 339 minus 2q a minus Q U
so now their marginal revenue is
actually a function of their own
behavior but their competitors behavior
that's the new marginal revenue function
okay now but the profit maximization
rules the same you just set that equal
to marginal cost
she said equal to 147 and you solve and
what you end up getting is the Q sub a
star the outcome Q sub a is 96 minus
one-half Q U star or qu q a star is 96
minus one-half qu if you solve this
equation that's what you get that's
one-half one-half qu so now we have the
optimal quantity but it's a function
what the other guy does that's a problem
except that we use the same math for
United now if the problem symmetric you
don't have to do the math again you know
the best response function will be
symmetric but that won't always be the
case so I'm gonna do a shortcut here of
saying the best response function for Q
you
is Q star u equals 96 minus 1/2 QA okay
so I've just written down their best
response functions correspond to the
graph look at the so Q star a that's the
blue line it's 96 minus one-half Q you
okay
choose star u that's a red line 96 minus
1/2 QA that's the best france function
now once again to remind you i could
simply skip to this step but normally
you have to solve through for both firms
they might not have identical best
response functions or symmetrical best
response function well now we're golden
we have two equations and two unknowns
we know how to deal with that and you
solve them and you get the Q a star
equals Q u star equals 64 you solve
those two equations two unknowns okay so
64 it's a solution to that system what's
the price
so in raise their hand and tell me
what's the price without looking at the
graph yeah and how did you get that you
gotta plug in 64 twice a lot of you'll
get this wrong you'll say Oh 339 minus
64 but no its 339 minus 128 because
they're each flying 64 and the price
comes from the total demand in the
market so the price is 211 okay that's
an important mistake to avoid a lot of
people get here they'll be super excited
they're tired they throw the 64 back of
the main equation but remember demands a
function of the total market if Symetra
gluts doing 64 then the price is gonna
be 211 and that is the Nash or cournot
equilibrium both firms are happy to fly
64 flights at a price of 2 11 neither
firm wants to deviate and you know that
because you've maximized their profits
and the profits for American are
maximized when United's lying 64 the
profits to American are maximized at
flying 64 when Americans flying 64 the
profits for United are maximized at
flying 64 therefore that is the national
equilibrium okay now when we get to
reality things might not always work out
so neatly things might not be symmetric
you might also not have an equilibrium
how could you not have an equilibrium
here how could that happen
graphically what would that mean yeah
yeah the best response occurs might not
intersect you might not get an
equilibrium we don't know what the hell
to do then all chaos breaks loose okay
but you might not get a knuckle Librium
okay in this market because the best
response curves might uh might not
intersect okay
in reality in life you could have funky
best response curves that are nonlinear
you can have multiple intersections you
could have multiple we call multiple
equilibria and then it becomes an
indeterminant problem and you have to
figure out which equlibrium they settle
at and that involves higher-order
mathematics that you talked about in
more advanced classes so this is sort of
the simplest easiest cases symmetric
case with linear best response functions
intersect is your easiest case but in
general the general way to solve this is
the same which is to look is to use the
principle of game theory look go back to
the prisoner's dilemma okay all we're
doing here was creating best response
functions it's just there wasn't a line
it was just a point the best response
function was what we laid out here all
we do is see United American examples go
to a continuum and about best response
functions is the best response point
okay yeah
other questions okay let's stop there
we'll come back next time we'll talk
about why don't we why don't we all just
get along like mr. Rogers wants